on faisait ça quand la route des
tamarins était en travaux en fait dont
il y avait personne on venait que les
week-ends pour
même que dimanche pour éviter toute gêne
à l'encontre de gros camions ou autre à
l'époque c'était fermé c'est bien peu
fréquenté la pénible ceci dit c'est un
bon rail de sheppard 3 4 minutes
ah ouais on s'éclate et bien on suivait
tous l'itinéraire ça partait d'ici de
l'éperon jusqu'à proviennent du à du ca
de saint paul ça fait 3 km 4 de descente
et voilà c'était sympa parce que
justement il y avait personne ils
tirèrent et et hop le bitume était tout
neuf donc voilà ça glissait bien de quoi
se mettre de bonnes boîtes et bonnes
sensations
une route qui est large déjà donc ça
nous permet de se faire aider pour plus
de sensations pour pouvoir freiner un
petit peu aussi
et une bonne descente pas des virages à
90 2
des sensations de vitesse qui montrent
beaucoup plus vite sensation de carvin
des bons virages on peut bien
s'accroupir sur la planche ou bien
rapide et dessus bien repartir dans le
sens et
pouvoir après se taper un shoot par
exemple en partant d'ici là des sentiers
légère et plus on arrive vers saint paul
plus à ce que ça s'accentue et donc la
vitesse commencé à bien s'accélérer donc
être plus souple pas comme moi étions
gamelle on en a pris certes notamment
une deux ans dans la petite vidéo on n'a
pas de casque on n'a pas de protection
c'est pas du tout à faire moi suisse à
ça je me suis acheté un casque et des
protections et ce que je conseille
voir
sur les remontées puisqu'on vous allez
remonter à pied on à moi j'ai eu quand
même le temps d'apprécier les paysages
dont les baleines
c'était la saison des bennes c'était
génial gic du coup ci dessous de 200
millions je savais rien des petites fire
en fait nous en tant qu'amateur ce qui
nous permettait d'y aller et pas trop se
faire mal c'est surtout la largeur de la
route qui en tant que novice et
débutants et amateurs qu'on fait nous
permettez en fait de ralentir c'est le
seul moyen qu'on avait de ralentir la
route fermée l'idéal quand on dit fermer
quatre voies pour nous tous seuls nous
on est partant pour une campagne
électorale en construction la qui fait
tout le tour
ça nous laisse deux trois ans que faire
voler on board